now someone by the name of shaggy Rogers
writes in if you don't mind what pilots
have you sold recently well there's two
that I have sold to production companies
this year one is a serial drama crime
serial drama let me do the logline it's
it's true detective meets ray Donovan
and it is a very very dark story about a
guy in Santa Monica we sat in Santa
Monica because it's Santa Monica is a
very corrupt town it's old drug money oh
really
oh yes and but he's a very dark hero and
he he he solves crimes but he does so
while well he actually saw him because
he's also he has the instincts of a
child molester and he's actually
kidnapped and keeps captive an 11 year
old girl in his basement
yes very dark yeah okay yeah so but he
doesn't molest her but and in fact she
becomes his ally Oh like the Stockholm
Syndrome kind of yes except for both of
them so he's battling this terrible
impulse inside of himself but because
he's battling it because he doesn't give
in to it
he actually develops a relationship with
her and it helps him solve crimes and
she becomes someone who helps in soft
crimes and who helps him heal so it's
very dark but it's it has its it's a
crime drama so there is there's it's an
episode and there's a there's a there's
a crime solved every a week but there's
also a long arc over the course of the
entire season and that's sort of
fashionable now to have both to have but
it's a discomforting premise it's it's
very raw and very dark and
and yeah it's it's um it's it's it's a
it's a dark dark crime drama and the
other one is the Jack Johnson miniseries
which is the miniseries so what I was
thinking to talk about today a little
bit was the fact that I've got this
superhero miniseries then I've also got
the serial drama where the guy doesn't
really heal in that crime drama he
doesn't really heal so his wound is
bleeding all through the season and will
continue to bleed all through the other
seasons he will never get healthy he
will never stop desiring underage girls
but it is a it's like a nuclear activist
contained fire but the struggle is
always there and how do you make him by
the way likable and sympathetic that was
the big question right because that's a
tough one right how do you make that
character like I'm unsympathetic what
about it like in Lolita well that's a
movie and I didn't particularly like
Humbert Humbert but I felt sympathy for
him because he was so he it was so
clearly he was gonna crash and burn
right I mean he was so in in thrall to
this awful awful desire he if he if he
could've he to givin it up yeah who
would want to be in thrall to this awful
desire right so that if you had sympathy
for Humbert Humbert it was that he's
he's doing something that he's gonna
earn him the opprobrium of everyone in
the world and yet he can't not do it
right he can't not do it so it's like
it's watching a guy who can't keep
himself from cutting his own throat he's
gonna he's gonna do it even though he
knows it's gonna kill him that's one of
the things in this sharp objects is that
she's a cutter and and yes yes and so so
our sympathy for her is that it's it's
wounding behavior that she can't help
and we see her pain and so I'm showing
and we're showing in this story because
I have a really brilliant co-writer in
this story as well I like working with
other people
Laurie Johnson is is her name that help
humanize this this guy this this
horrible guy by showing that he was the
victim of an insane horrible father and
that he not only has a genetic
propensity which he has to be to have
this this twisted sexuality but he also
his his own sister was raped and killed
by his father and he had to watch it and
and and and watch all of that happen so
we get that story and he's also suicidal
so we get all that story in in the pilot
which is important when you have someone
this awful you've got to make quickly
show something that makes them more
sympathetic or you've lost your audience
entirely and maybe you should I mean I
know people think Hollywood is horrible
for even entertaining the idea that that
a character should be sympathetic right
so that's part of the controversy too
she do even have a character audience on
the air hmm I don't know but it's it's a
powerful story so that's those are the
two I'm most involved with right now but
I'm always open for more you know I love
collaborating with people it's my thing
and I always want to go and teach or
talk somewhere I often get somebody to
come bring music and what do you think
of this story and a lot of the times
like I say yeah let's do it
um I'm excited to put my learning to use
with somebody else and their vision it
seems to be kind of the way I work the
best okay
hiding behind someone else and then if
it's not good hey it's their fault
I did the best I could that sounds like
a good plan yeah it's great